[Music]
mmm are you kidding me are you ready to
begin the bougie burger bonanza that
looks insane
oh my god
yo what though
a three digit burger so this would be
like a 400 burger 1200 burger
[Music]
we're making a chili
cheese patty melt with a short rib
stuffed inside it clearly my friends at
the make-a-wish foundation got my
message got this dry aged patty throw
some cheese on it we're gonna top it
with a little bit of chili i feel like
i'm watching someone paint a picasso got
that smoked beef rib texas style used a
little bit of oak on that uh this is the
part where i grab my phone because i got
to take a picture of this i'm going to
pull the bow now you're going to take
this entire thing and dip it into the
queso oh
my bam god he pulled a bone out of my
sandwich
and now i have to dip it in cheese beef
rib chili coconut queso i need four
hands take it backwards to the face
[Music]
are you kidding me are you kidding me
boom
wow a5 miyazaki bms 11. i don't even
know those numbers so what i have here
is
finely finely chopped a5 this is
luxurious
this is like
the first time i've ever seen this this
is about 135 a pound this would cost us
about 210 bucks at a restaurant amazing
so i got hokkaido milk bread here
lightly toasted with beef butter i'm
adding a little smoked shoyu aioli from
japan we fish scale
with tsukemono pickles that looks insane
oh my god razor blade cut fried garlic
scallions so we're going to live wow
i can't believe i get to eat this so
there you go wow enjoy we we
get oh my gosh what are we thinking it's
like so it's so rich and flavorful
oh my god
that's really good
yo man this is the most baller burger
i've ever even looked at i don't know if
i've ever had this many opulent
ingredients on any single dish it's a
bat i'm gonna tell you it's 295 dollars
so this burger has japanese wagyu beef
stuffed with 10 herb white truffle
butter seasoned with smoked sea salt
topped with the ballingest cheddar aged
18 months in england shaved black
truffle a fried quail egg white truffle
butter buttered onto this companion roll
topped with a bellini creme fraiche
caviar and it's got a diamond encrusted
toothpick and gold dust my g
this is it's bougie
i can't eat all this i think sometimes
when it gets so fancy it gets a little
bit inaccessible and i can appreciate
the culinary merit but is it gonna hit
that burger crate
we're gonna make an amazing steakhouse
burger
yo what the
116 days dry age american wagyu beef
ribeye
tomahawk we're turning this into a
hamburger
you hear that
that's that's magic sounds [ __ ] sexy
we'll get a little bit of this truffle
mayo i'm going to flip it over
oh
we got that caramelization right there
right do this circular motion
it's like bubbling already a little bit
of white truffle we're going to shave
this white shuffle what i have right
here is caviar series so we're going to
top the burger
this is the rich brian steakhouse steak
burger just the meat alone was 300 we
put about 100 worth of caviar on it that
little baby piece of truffle like 125
bucks are you serious so this would
probably be like a 400 dollar burger
marked up
ridiculous wow when i took a bite of
this i swear my life just like flashed
before my eyes
oh look at this okay yo if you buy this
burger it comes with a record player
yeah this is a twelve hundred dollar
burger
oh you like that that's true why are you
you should
it starts off with a5 wagyu patty it's
basted with truffle vilju sake rubbed
cheddar the house made purple okinawa
potato roll it has msg mayo the
mushrooms that you can only get in the
fall roasted campari tomatoes yeah you
got to like let it fly on there
this truffle stink i ain't gonna lie to
this
ass cheeks you trying to have me eat
that
all right what are you thinking give me
some history some feedback before i take
my second bite into like to some people
that flavor that earthy flavor
is balling i bite into this it feel like
i just bit into an old couch cushion
i picked the burgundy 1200 yeah yeah
the most expensive most elite full
experience of a burger cheers to this
it don't get no more baller than that
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up y'all it's your boy alvin
kylon of the burger show make sure you
like subscribe and hit that notification
bell
if not for me
for the burgers